bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono vari j e oggi ho
fatto la intro più tranquilla da quando
esistono incredibile se ci pensate
perché messo a mai sentita questo volume
giampiero non deve abbassarsi in editing
quindi è tutto perfetto oggi i ragazzi
però giochiamo ad aki nator che non so
se lo conoscete miley che cacchio
proprio non so se molti voi sanno che ho
o due tatuaggi che sono questo che ciò
dal 2015 più o meno si è questo quadro
sono una ballerina minucci di f ciò a
qualcuno che questo mi fa ridere gianni
bravo in realtà quel sia questo che
quello che sulla gamba sono due
personaggi di due serie che non c'entra
una mazza una collana sono crash
bandicoot ed è note vediamo se akin
editore in grado di indovinarli non ne
ho idea ma tentar non nuoce le scotte
sera il tema della prossima partita
personaggio o animali vi è il
personaggio partiamo con
con l di turn off che il più semplice
tra i due perché acqua q è un po
complicati know però dai vediamo
personaggi nella sanità italiana l
italiano non no perché mi pare sia un
altro vorrei una cacata impressionato in
inghilterra chiavi chi non ha visto
death note ci credete il video perché
non meritate di discrete di anche tuo
personaggio è veramente esistito
purtroppo no è maschio al sole perché
questo c'è una tarantola in faccia
quanti problemi le pubblicità quanti
dover sono già fa parte di mani me
cartone animato giapponese siamo alla
quarta domanda come ha fatto è il
protagonista della perenco e appare non
è protagonista
dipende in realtà perché dipenderà da
come guardi detta comunque la vetta ai
capelli scuri orie ha ai poteri speciali
a hong hao
combatte o un beh dipende un paio di
calci li ha tirati anche fare quel mondo
dello sport ha anche già consacra tennis
lavora con la polizia oyeah ha scritto
la fiaba la gatta cenerentola
a chi network e cosa che i fumi la sera
ha creato un'app per smartphone
il tuo personaggio sospetta del
protagonista vabbè dai la sai billo yes
camon
caramella assolutamente simili a quanti
hanno ridato 64.000 porca vacca
aggiungi un'immagine migliore
no vabbè non lo facciamo rimetta mio
tipo però lasciamo perdere farei ragazzi
uno su due e l'abbiamo preso uno su
della mia preso vediamo a quota a
qualcuno ragazzi un personaggio della
serie videoludica crash bandicoot per
chi non lo sapesse vi siete già iscritti
paradisi iscrivetevi nuovi il tuo
personaggio combatte e si cenno no vabbè
di penn non facciamo che li facciamo
nuova prima domandato la sangio e
femmina no aquapur non credo che mi ha
dei capelli neri il fatto che per
vederlo devo spezzare le gambe non hai
capelli neri e capelli la coppa di tipo
sixty nine e molto a dei poteri speciali
si è molto difficile questa ragazza i
quali prima racca gatte in confronto è
cattivo no il cattivo ragazzi uka uka
che questo qua è il protagonista è la
paradis cui pare no ai capelli bianchi
no ai capelli beh non so se sono
considerati i capelli le piume che in
testa dunque
no indossa vestiti il no è tutto no è un
pokemon non è un voto ha l'aspetto di un
animale no fa parte di un anime no
cammina sulle gambe e tutto no finge di
stare con olivia wilde
fa parte videogioco ora ci siamo siamo
in videogiochi non è protagonista non ha
i capelli potremmo esserci il tuo
messaggio a tre gatti
che corre in pista può dio oddio se
giochi a ctr che sarebbe gioco di tipo
il mario kart e di crescenti così
comunque no
complimenti non so che dire abbiamo
ragazzi indovinato tutti e due i
tatuaggi cosa molto complicata
complimenti veramente arrivati ragazzi a
questo punto non so se a chi nator in
grado di dominare proprio tutti tutti
però proviamo a vedere se vado su
animali voglio provare a vedere se
riesce a indovinare in qualche modo il
mio cane sun sinceramente non ne ho la
minima idea però scontro furioso questo
punto il tool animale vive con degli
umani il rivale mia gola no il pari ma
ne piccolo il tuo animale a che fare con
i cani è un cane quindi boe alle
orecchie appuntite no non so ragazzi se
può indovinarlo effetti l'hype che
insomma è un po complicato non sono meno
indovinerebbe neanche mio padre tu hai
il mare può essere trovato in una piazza
certo quando fa la pipì la fa ovunque
non guarda in faccia nessuno vide ed i
due colori non sa parlare quasi però no
e bianco vive soprattutto notte porca
tra sì però mettiamo di noah il sedere
bianco al culo make a calto no fa sesso
una volta ha tentato di indro farmi una
gamba però non penso valga sei
affezionato al tuo animale
certo però va bene è il tuo animale è
posseduto da te allora il discorso è che
se metto sì lui dice è il tuo cane ok
quindi la risposta giusta ma io voglio
che di casa e quindi devo dire no il tuo
animale potrà ricorrere portasi no
sì ho capito però di vino e il nome
voglio il nome hai sbagliato notte
pensando a san
forse potrebbe essere su personaggio
perché magari siccome famoso non lo
mettono c'è perché animali lui mette
tipo giraffa zebra forse dobbiamo andare
su personaggio per trovarlo proprio
miratamente capitano lo so vediamo tito
personaggi indossa le scarpe no se le
mangia il passaggio animale si medi
forse domandare suo personaggio
attenzione era perché quello sono famosi
si va lì se non se ne indovina un
animale generico esso animato che questo
non lo sapevo il tuo personaggio fa
parte di un cartone animato absolutely
not ma non ci starebbe malissimo fa
parte di un videogioco i no ma non ci
starebbe male manco la è un cane apslo
play ti conosce purtroppo sì esiste
davvero assoluto ei s vive con uno
youtuber
ci siamo è uno dei match contro c'è
ma non è né coccolato da lui né
coccolato da soffitto che io sappia
brano fa parte del film horror e
rispetto sì cazzolato per quanto vorrei
mettere sì perché effettivamente si
onora e si rispetta sums a che fare con
parigi e perfetto perfetto perfetto non
ho altro anno altri animali direi che ci
siamo va bene
perché questa perché perché tutto ciò
perché fa parte di acam e gac il e
bellissimo quando architetto l'indovina
quello che sta cercando indovinare e poi
fa domande a cazzo che non c'entrano
niente ha quindi conduce amici di maria
de filippi si
fa parte di giurgiu kaiser nozze con due
amici maria de filippi nord ju jitsu
casa il tuo personaggio fa parte di aca
mega film vive con famiglie se tra detto
prima di sì
ecco
perché foto è che foto è questa per
cortesia con questi va bene il 2008 16
mila volte pensate come cazzo sta messo
sto cane ecco perché appaia sempre gli
fischiano le orecchie cia l'otite
poverino limite perché pensano tutti
comunque ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto questo era una clinton è un po
particolare per di avetrana non poi lo
faceva di network per sempre bello farà
sempre bello cosa i ragazzi ci viene più
dal suo momento è un mi piace anche una
risorsa che come descrizione chelsea
iscrivetevi è mai come sempre ci vediamo
al prossimo video di a pineto al fatemi
sapere anche se volete che gli faccia
indovinare qualcosa magari mettetevi un
commento o qualche suggestione e io il
prossimo rientro che faccio li prendo
direttamente nei commenti vediamo che
esce fuori e intanto ci abbiamo proposto
ai ragazzi
[Musica]